[Musique]
en fait elles seront deux déclaré l'état
d'urgence écologique
premier point et deuxième point mettre
en place ce qu'on appelle une
constituante communal pourrait définir
le fonctionnement démocratique de la
ville de besançon et notamment la
question du riq référendum d'initiative
citoyenne qu'on veut mettre en place
je dirais que le principal atout qu'on a
c'est la diversité de notre liste et les
les compétences incroyable des candidats
et les candidates qui est sur notre
liste qui sont tous très très compétents
dans leur domaine mais qui viennent de
la société civile qui viennent qui sont
des militants associatifs qui sont des
gilets jaunes donc il ya vraiment une
compétence une expertise dans plein de
domaines
je vous dis alors qu'est ce que je peux
dire ah bah voilà je sais moi j'ai
trouvé alors notre principal handicap
j'ai envie de dire que c'est un petit
peu le le jeu médiatique tel qu'il se
pratique qui a tendance à favoriser ceux
qui apparaissent en point dans les
sondages à un moment donné mais qu'un
handicap qui est classique pour notre
camp mais je vais pas le qualifier lui
parce que en tant que personne ça
m'intéresse pas trop
mais son dernier mandat était vraiment
le mandat trop c'était trop long et et
ça a été une catastrophe